if you're looking for a step-by-step
walkthrough of going from data to
pre-processing to training a machine
learning model and all the way to
deployment in the cloud with detailed
step-by-step explanation
well this talk is for you with over 500
sessions at next 2018 it's totally
understandable that you couldn't get to
them all so if you didn't see
forecasting stock returns with
tensorflow cloud ml engine and thomson
reuters tick data in bigquery then stay
tuned because here's the rewind this
session walked through in detail the
queries the code and the configurations
used to train a model on stock market
tick data sourced from Thomson Reuters
specifically the aim of this model was
to predict returns on a 5-minute horizon
of market information now this project
it's somewhat special and that's because
it's really doing everything in a cloud
the data is in the cloud the
pre-processing is done in the cloud and
the training of the machine learning
model well it's also done in the clock
this means that even though the
particular model they ended up using was
pretty simple and the training data
selected was over a fairly limited time
frame just five minutes the solution
that was designed it works from the
Gecko to scale up to a much bigger data
set and a much more sophisticated model
now concretely the data has pulled out a
big gray with a couple of different SQL
queries and then it's loaded into a
panda's data frame from there it's
transformed into TF record files this is
ideal for sending over to tensorflow
training especially if the data were to
then scale up in the future there's a
great explanation than talk of using
feature columns and the features spec
utility functions to make constructing
an input function much much easier and
as is often the case the simplest part
of the process and then of being the
actual model building now for the
training of this model the model was
trained on cloud ml engine and there's a
detailed walkthrough of the
configuration file and setup process
that was used empowering you to not only
be able to reproduce this workflow but
then extend it this session was very
much a how-to
so if you're ready to dive into the
world of running machine learning in the
cloud head on over to the full talk and
get training if you like this video give
it a thumbs up I've included the link to
the full talk down in the description
below so be sure to check that out and
don't forget to subscribe to the cloud
youtube channel for more great content
I'll see you on the next rewind
[Music]